hey you guys welcome back to my flickers
of fear movie review show
all right so i can think of like a
handful of horror movies like recent
ones that i've actually talked about
that were either set in wales or were
directed by like a welsh director
or were filmed there um some of those
would be like a dark song uh saint mod
sensor like some movies like that
as i said i've talked about those three
prior like on this channel
but i don't think that i've ever seen a
horror movie
that was entirely in the welsh language
i i know that's a thing but honestly
like um if you don't know uh a long time
ago like i used to be married to a welsh
man
and so i went back and forth to wales
like quite a lot like from about the mid
1990s to like the late 2000s so i saw a
lot of welsh language content i mean i
was i was in south wales and they speak
english as well but they do teach welsh
in schools and they did have a channel
that was like about half welsh
programming but i'd never seen a horror
movie that was entirely in welsh before
so i thought that was kind of neat uh
when i heard about this movie which is
called
the feast
now this came out back in 2021
and it's the debut feature from a
director named lee haven jones who i
believe has just worked in television
prior i think they did some uh doctor
who episodes or something like that
um and this kind of premiered back at
south by southwest i think film festival
back in 2021 it got a little bit of
positive buzz there and i think a lot of
people thought it was kind of cool
because it was like novelty and it's
like oh this is like the first i don't
it's probably not the first one but it's
kind of the first one to get kind of
like a really wide release of like a
horror film that's in welsh
so the feast which in welsh is known as
glyph if i'm pronouncing that right
glyph something like that
i took a little bit of welsh a long time
ago but my pronunciation's not that good
uh this is actually kind of like a
really slow burn
vaguely folkloric uh kind of eat the
rich fantasy
and it goes it starts out like that but
then goes like full on gross out body
horror like in the third act
now this movie is kind of like a strange
journey
and it's definitely not for all tastes i
mean like nothing is but you know what i
mean i mean i like my slow burn horror
and stuff like that but i will say
i think the first two acts of this were
slightly too ponderous and kind of like
tried my patience a couple of times
but
at the same time i was almost like so
interested in like what was gonna happen
that i couldn't really look away from it
you know what i mean even though
sometimes like some of the shots like
lingered a little too long or something
i was just like okay like what's going
on let's get on with it but in the end i
think it was like a pretty rewarding
experience your mileage may vary yeah so
it's it's pretty languidly paced at
least until the end
this gave me in its themes and a little
bit in its cinematography it gave me a
little bit of a vibe of parasite but
without like any of the black humor you
know what i mean it's kind of like
thematically similar to parasite
so here's the setup for the feast
we have this wealthy london-based family
of mostly insufferable [ __ ]
and they're hosting this little dinner
party at their really like boxy looking
modern vacation home which i guess it's
like their second home in the sort of
like rolling hills this beautiful welsh
countryside
so the dad is this blowhard alky named
gwen
and he is a corrupt member of parliament
and he's one of those real like kind of
like macho man like i'm kind of know
everything type of dudes it's like one
of the things that he's that he does
like over the course of the movie is
that he has to tell everybody like
repeatedly oh i shot the rabbits that
were having for dinner even though in
reality he didn't shoot them he just
found them dead but he it was very
important to him that everybody thinks
that he shot them like he was a big
family man or something like that so
there's that guy
then you have the mom who's named glenda
who's very vain very class conscious
and she ended up um inheriting this
farmland that the house uh was built on
and she got it from her parents they got
it from their parents so it's been like
in the family for generations
uh but she's made like boatloads of cash
recently like in the last few years by
selling off parcels of the family land
to a mining company for drilling
then you got uh the creeper son gwyriv
who is like they're they're both grown
sons both of them they're not like
little kids or anything so he's like
this pale weirdo
who
wears unitards like shaves his balls
um he's always like looking at himself
in the mirror like rubbing himself all
over like oh my god i'm so into myself
like that kind of thing like yeah he's
super creepy and you find out that he
was he's either a doctor or a medical
student i can't remember which which it
was but he's taken like a sabbatical
from that um in order to train for a
triathlon so you see him like in these
ridiculous like exercise-y outfits like
you know on the stationary bike and he's
like eating this really weird like
limited diet and all this other kind of
stuff and he's like really obnoxious
about it so there's that yeah he's like
a total weirdo
and then uh you have the other son whose
name is guto
and he's sort of like this rebellious
musician type you know with like all the
black clothes and everything and he was
actually
he really loves london he loves like the
big city life nightclubs and parties and
everything like that but
he got into
uh drugs i guess he was like a heroin
addict so his family like made him come
out here to the country like to recover
so both of the both of the sons are sort
of like a shame on their family i guess
just because the one is like dropped out
of medical school or whatever so he
could go be in a triathlon and the other
one's like a druggie
but i will say that guto is actually the
most sympathetic out of the whole
unpleasant family
because he seems to be the only one with
anything approaching
uh like a sense of empathy toward others
or like a conscience or anything like
that he's still kind of a douche but
not not nearly as much as the other ones
and he also seems to like hate the rest
of his family like as much as we the
viewer are meant to so there's that and
in his defense if this was my family i
would totally be taking all the drugs
too so i can feel that so anyway into
this sort of simmering familial tension
i guess
comes
caddy
and she's this mysterious young woman
and she's supposedly like showing up at
the house
in order to uh she's like an assistant
she's supposed to like help glenda set
up the dinner party
apparently what happened was that the
girl that glenda usually hired wasn't
available for whatever reason so cotty
was apparently like recommended like as
to use as like a backup
pretty much from the beginning though
you can tell that there's i mean there's
something really off-kilter
and maybe possibly even malevolent about
this young woman
pretty much like for the first maybe
half of the movie she doesn't i don't
even think she speaks at all or if she
does like maybe it's like a word or two
here or there so she barely speaks her
hair is like either
well i mean i know which it is but it's
like a spoiler alert but um her hair is
just like looked like greasy or wet the
whole time
um she seems like she always has dirt on
her hands even though you don't really
see her like putting dirt on her hands
but she always seems to get things dirty
but then like when they show her hands
there's no dirt there so there's that
and she seems to spend a lot of the time
uh just kind of like staring intently at
members of the family
and uh kind of spacing out when she's
supposed to be working
and also when no one is watching her she
sort of like creeps through the house
like spying on people like you know she
goes in glenda's bedroom like tries on
her earrings in the mirror and like
cackles and it's a little bit unnerving
like to say the least
now there is actually one time that
caddy sort of acts
normal and that's when glenda kind of
comes into the kitchen and she overhears
katie singing this old folk song while
she's sitting there making the canapes
or whatever
now glenda is actually quite enchanted
by this she's like oh my gosh i remember
that song like my grandma used to sing
that to me or something like that like
from her childhood she remembers it it's
an old folk song so her and katie like
kind of sing together and laugh and it's
almost like a normal moment
uh but that is pretty much the last time
that katie will do anything that's not
remotely weird like for the rest of the
movie she's just a weird weird girl
so the dinner guests start to show up
first you have this dude named
euros i think his name is euros who's
like kind of the slick businessman type
uh he's also kind of like a total claude
he shows up super early like before
they're even set up um he brings them
like a wine bottle and he like slips and
drops it like and it breaks all over the
driveway
and he's one of those guys like he'll
totally like he'll just light up a
cigarette without asking like should i
go outside and anytime food like comes
by like within reach he'll just like
reach out and like stuff it in his face
he's not fat or anything like he's real
skinny but he'll eat pretty much
anything that's not nailed down
apparently now it turns out that this is
like a none too subtle metaphor i
suppose because euros
well i guess you could say that he's
like a friend of the [ __ ] that own
this house but he's more like a business
associate because what he is he's kind
of like a business broker
and what he does is he sort of like
helps people that own land like make the
most money out of that land so he's been
brokering this deal with this family for
a long time where they they're selling
off the land like to get drilled like
looking for minerals and stuff like that
so the fact that he eats everything
like that he's always like stuff in his
face like i think there's one point like
when everybody's at the table and
they're just like oh don't wait for us
and he's like oh okay then starts like
craving food into his face and stuff
like that so they're trying to like show
that he's sort of like the the epitome
of like the greedy businessman that like
consumes everything in sight or like
consumes everything he touches so
there's that like i said it's not super
subtle but you know it's not super in
your face either to this dinner party
there are only two other guests invited
and only one of them turns up showing up
this is a kind of dowdy farm woman named
maier and she rents the adjoining
property like from the main family and i
think that they've lived on the land for
like for generations so maya and her
husband have lived on this land for a
long time um i think their parents lived
there and like rented from glenda's
parents it was that and that maya and
glenda actually grew up together out
here like this is before because the
house they're in now like was just
recently built because glenn is talking
about oh it took so long to get it right
and blah blah blah now myers husband was
actually supposed to come to the party
as well but myer tells the family she's
like oh there was an accident like not
too far away in which there was like a
car went into the lake or the river or
whatever and they've had to like pull it
out so her husband i can't remember what
his name was it started with an eye but
i can't remember what it was but um you
never see him in the thing he's just
like talked about
but he apparently said he would like
loan the authorities as tractor like to
help them get the the car out of the
lake or whatever so glenda ends up
giving mayor like the grand tour of the
house because like i said it's only
recently been built so i'm assuming that
mayor has not been there now glenda is
obviously very like pleased with herself
very impressed with her own wealth and
status uh it seems
but maier who's just kind of like a
simple down-to-earth farm woman
she kind of thinks the place is really
cold really like forbidding
and in particular um glenda takes her to
this to this sort of spa room that she
has like at the end of this long haul
and she calls it like her retreat they
actually even show her at the beginning
with like one of those like charcoal
like uh masks like on her face you know
what i mean and she's in there like
zenning out or whatever but my ear looks
at it she's like it kind of looks like a
prison cell which it absolutely does
because it just has these great brick
walls and [ __ ] like that
so it's pretty clear like through these
sort of like awkward interactions that
my ear is kind of like very troubled by
this sort of like grasping harpy that
her childhood friend has become like
what wealth has done to her so as the
story goes on uh we discover that pretty
much the sole purpose of this dinner
party was not to like just have friends
over neighbors or whatever but what
they're trying to do is they have euros
there because he's trying to talk meyer
and her husband
into selling off their part of the land
or like not selling it but like allowing
like signing the contract to allow the
mining company to like drill there and
look for minerals the land that they
farm also has this other part of it that
they don't farm on that's called the
rise and you learn like later on that
there's sort of like
legends in the area like about that
particular uh place why they don't farm
on it
now
when maier learns the reason for this
dinner party like why she's been asked
here she's like pretty horrified she's
like look um this land has been in both
of our families like for generations the
farm makes us you know sufficient money
we're not really worried about it i
think i'd rather like carry on the way i
have been like doing the farm we're
doing fine um she's like i don't really
want to kind of like
rape the land
in order to like make a few extra bucks
just so i can buy like some shitty art
like you have here now she doesn't say
that but that's kind of probably what
she's thinking so while all of this
tomfoolery is going on in the foreground
cody is lurking around in the background
doing some increasingly weird [ __ ]
including like she takes i believe it's
like the dish of rabbit like out of the
fridge or the cooler or whatever and
sort of like discreetly vomits into it
no it doesn't look like she does it on
purpose but like she's grossed out and
then she kind of vomits a little bit and
she's like oh well i guess i'll just
leave that in there kind of thing she's
maybe putting hair in their food it's
not entirely clear every now and then
she goes outside and like starts rolling
around in the dirt and like all the
vines kind of like commons do like an
evil dead kind of moment not exactly
like that but you know what i mean also
pretty early on in the film remember i
said like when euros showed up and he
dropped the wine bottle and it broke all
over the driveway well katie went out
there and she's like oh interesting this
big uh piece of glass and she straight
up inserts that right into her uh little
squishment in there and uh so you know
that that's gonna be like setting up a
trap for later on you know what i mean
and indeed uh that does actually uh come
to pass so you know just wait for it so
it becomes pretty obvious as and this
isn't really a spoiler i guess but you
know if you'd really rather not know
anything about this movie then you know
might want to like click off and go
watch it and come back like i said
i don't know because i feel like it's
pretty obvious from very early on in the
movie as but as it gets toward the
finale as everything gets nastier and
bloodier and more maggoty uh and things
like that that caddy might not actually
be exactly human that she might be
essentially like the embodiment of this
sort of like folkloric like nature
spirit that is supposed to like protect
the land around here
so as i mentioned earlier uh this is a
pretty slow burn
so it's gonna be up to you
whether the kind of disgusting bloodbath
at the end is worth the wait
i think to a large extent i personally
thought that it was the characters and
the family dynamic is weird enough
that it really kind of keeps your
attention like for the first like
two-thirds of the movie where it's kind
of like languid and like sort of
ponderous and even though you kind of
maybe sort of like know what katie is up
to
but
she's acting like so strange and like so
off-putting that that also makes it like
really intriguing like what the [ __ ] is
this [ __ ] after like what's she gonna
do next you know what i mean like while
she's like lurking around back there so
as i mentioned the cinematography is
gorgeous um there's a big contrast
between the sort of you know the the
nature versus modernity type thing
because you have like these kind of
bucolic like rolling welsh hills and
everything like that and then it's
contrasted against
this very modern very ugly squat
square
house that's just kind of like sitting
here in the midst of all this beauty and
it's sort of just like made of this
brownish gray brick and it's in the
house has like all these big glass
windows but it's almost kind of like
looking out onto nature but still like
keeping it at one remove type of thing
and it just has these long dark hallways
and it's sort of like it just looks very
empty and soulless which is kind of
reflecting the family that lives within
it so there's that as well now i mean
the nature's revenge
theme of the movie it's not exactly
subtle
but it doesn't really hit you in the
face with it either you know i think it
hit it gets a nice balance between
having i don't know if i want to say it
has like a message but it does have you
know that kind of theme to it where you
know rich people that are like raping
the land are taking all the resources
and like nature taking revenge type
thing but i don't think it's too overt
with it it's not heavy-handed even
though the you know the metaphors and
stuff like that are not really all that
subtle but it doesn't like like i said
hit you in the face with obviousness now
it's not the movie's not scary per se
likes no jump scares there's nothing
like that but it is it does have this
weird like disquieting
uh type of vibe and like it's kind of
eerie
and some of the body horror stuff at the
end is actually like pretty satisfyingly
gross like i said there's like big
maggoty legs and
there's a lot of like kind of eat things
to do with like eating like eating
you know people's flesh and you know
eating maggots and [ __ ] like that so
it's like that kind of [ __ ] but and it's
plus like it's super bloody too
and as i mentioned earlier it's kind of
like refreshing to see a horror movie
that is in a language that you don't
really see i don't i've never seen any
i'm sure there are some but i've never
seen any horror movie that was entirely
in welsh before so it was like kind of
neat to see that because it's a novelty
so i feel like it's almost worth
watching just for that because you just
don't see that many and particularly in
the united states you don't see a lot of
welsh language movies period but you
particularly don't see any welsh
language horror so i thought that was
like kind of cool especially like i said
since i've been to wales a lot of times
so i thought that was kind of uh nice to
see so if you've seen the feast uh i
believe it's streaming on amazon prime
but i think you have to pay if you have
hulu it's on there for free though
that's where i watched it
so if you've seen it or if it sounds
interesting to you then let me know in
the comments uh what your thoughts about
it are and we'll have a discussion and
that'll do it for this flickers of fear
i will see you guys on the next one bye